en début d'après midi un appel est logé
au 9 1 1
il est question d'un vol qualifié dans
un immeuble du boulevard saint-laurent
dans le mile end
des rumeurs circulent il y aurait des
otages rapidement des dizaines de
policiers certains lourdement armés
arrivent sur place des membres du groupe
tactique d'intervention en camions
blindés et des maîtres chiens font aussi
à pied d'oeuvre dans le quartier
l'inquiétude est palpable
le géant français ubisoft serait visé
des centaines d'employés ils sont
barricadés c'est une intervention qu
elle a extrêmement sérieuse thomas et
jonathon une amie à l'intérieur sans
nouvelles d'elle ils ont décidé de se
déplacer
ce serait ça mais on attend on est là et
le périmètre est à ses gars plusieurs
rues sont bouclées le périmètre s'étend
sur des centaines de mètres les
policiers demandent aux résidents de
rester à l'intérieur aux autres d'éviter
le secteur
c'est inquiétant ce que c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose
enfin c'est quand même un endroit que je
considérais pas comme à risque ou autre
et c'est vrai que voir comme ça la
situation ça surprend ça fait ça fait
peur quelque part au milieu de l'après
midi de nouvelles rumeurs se répandent
il s'agirait finalement d'une fausse
alerte peu avant 16 heures le spvm
affirme qu aucune menace n'a été
détectée mais l'opération se poursuit
on va continuer l'opération vraiment
jusqu'à la fin pour s'assurer vraiment
la sécurité de tout le monde donc toutes
les informations qu'ils entrent sont
vérifiés sont validés pendant ce temps
les employés confinés à l'intérieur
d'ubisoft sont évacués par petits
groupes ils sont plus de 200 au total
ils vont rencontrer les enquêteurs
peu importe la nature finalement de
l'événement c'est une opération qui peut
quand même avoir rien n'est pas que
certaines personnes
donc on va s'assurer qu'ils aient le
support requis ubi soft offrira aussi un
soutien à ses employés l'entreprise
s'est dite bouleversée par les
événements mais soulagé de son
dénouement
ici qui me permettrait au canada
montréal